Hi there everyone. This is Keith Moore,
he's the head librarian at the Royal
Society. Some of you may recognise him
already,
a lot of you won't. We're going to show
you something, and then I'll tell you
something else about Keith that's really
interesting. This is a letter from the
archives at the Royal Society and it's
written by one very famous mathematician
to another one. It's written by John
Herschel to Charles Babbage. This is no
formal boring stuffy letter, in fact
Keith - tell us a little bit about what
this says.
- Well this is from quite an early
period in the life of Herschel and
Babbage, so this is 1817, they're
quite young men.
They're talking about George Peacock, one
of their mathematician friends; they're
talking about an election certificate
for something, it doesn't quite
say what. But
what Herschel says is that 'Peacock is a
noodle for neglecting it so, and if you
have done the
same' - that's Babbage - 'you are a
'doodle. Aye, digest it as you may,
a doodle-doo!'
These are senior scientists, Brady.
(Brady: They're calling each other
noodles and doodles and-)
I know, yeah-
(Brady: Mathematicians...)
- They're quite young.
- Anyway, the thing I want to
show all of you, the
Numberphile viewers, is what's on the
next page of this letter, because it's
quite interesting to look at and it
might be a bit of a puzzle; let's have a
look what's next here. I'm going to turn
the page; now the letter continues here
on the left, and you can see it's signed
off with the signature of Herschel
himself, but what's really interesting is
here on this facing page. Besides a
little bit of the original wax there,
from sealing the letter, he's written
something here. Keith, what has he written?
I'm not doing that to sort of bring you
into the video, I'm doing it because I
can't read the handwriting!
What's he written here?
- So what he's said
is a P.S. almost is 'interpret this
hieroglyphic, it contains a great
discovery'.
- So apparently, hidden within
this picture,
that Herschel, the famous Herschel, has
drawn and sent to the equally famous
Babbage is some kind of discovery- is
there a mystery? A puzzle? What's
going on?
- So you- what you have here is this
central figure which Herschel says is
'Dionysius, the God of
functions, alias the genius of abstract
numerical magnitude'. And you can see that
he's surrounded not just by some random
figures here but some of the drawing
itself is made up of numbers. So you can
probably see 1s and 0s here, and
there's a little bit on the end so; what
Herschel is saying is hidden in here
there's something very important. I kind
of doubt it but maybe the viewers can
tell us.
- I don't know, neither of us are
mathematicians-
- Well, that's right we need help.
- Okay. I will put an image of this
elsewhere on the Internet, you can check
out the video description, there'll be
more information. But if you find things
like this interesting, if you love these
old documents, old scientific objects,
things like that; Keith and I get
together every week on another YouTube
channel called Objectivity - there'll be a
link to that on the screen, in the
description. Sometimes it's stuff like this,
sometimes it's machines, sometimes it's
telescopes; we did one with Isaac
Newton's telescope - every week a really
cool new object. We've done nearly 30 of
them already, check it out if it's
something you haven't seen already. And
if you do watch it, well, thanks. And
thanks for this Keith, I'm going to get
to work her figuring this out.
- Thank you!
[Preview] There we go, oh
there we go look. So there's
the Earth turning as I turn the handle,
day to night. Seriously I love this thing,
I think I think if the Royal Society was
on fire - which I hope never
happens - this
would be one of the things I would grab.